LasVegas gunman Steven paddock was a
familiar presence at casinos around
Nevada addict ooh a lot of time gambling
in the days before the attack was part
of an elite group of wealthy high
rollers and owners in Las Vegas with how
those big-money gamblers have set apart
on casino floors and a good morning good
morning well here on the strip there are
different kinds of gamblers those who
come with fun money and those who come
with serious money and it's those
serious gamblers like Steven paddock who
are usually treated quite a bit
differently
they're the people casinos want to hold
on to high rollers who spend tens of
thousands of dollars and are repeat
customers helping to keep casinos bottom
lines flush and Eric paddock told
reporters his brother liked to gamble
and he text me a picture of you know
that he won $40,000 on the slot machine
but that's the way sources tell CBS News
that over a dozen currency transaction
reports were generated related to pattex
gambling those reports are filed when
$10,000 or more is moved through a
banking system or casino anybody who's
going to be playing at the levels that
have been reported for him puts him in
high-low high-roller status for sure
Anthony Curtis is a former professional
gambler who runs web site the Las Vegas
advisor
he says assuming paddock was gambling
with high amounts of money he would be
able to get a lot of perks complimentary
Zoar comps from the casinos that you
know definitely had a very high level
and when he walks through the door do
they know who he is right away
absolutely when he comes through the
door there's gonna be things waiting for
him he's going to be able to request the
sort of accommodations that he wants
high rollers often get their meals
tickets to shows and even their rooms
comped in other words free according to
the Associated Press paddocks Mandalay
Bay Suites Sunday night was one he
specifically requested and got for free
because he gambled thousands at the
hotel's casino University of Nevada Las
Vegas Gaming professor David Schwartz
says what high rollers ask for they
usually get generally the idea is if you
can get it and of course if it's legal
you don't want them leaving your hotel
to go to another hotel to get it so they
will try to accommodate all
sorts of things like that well Curtis
told us there are actually relatively
few true high rollers here on the strip
so casinos are competing to keep the
ones they do have Nora
alright Anna thank you so much I mean
VIP treatment is nothing new but it's
certainly very different the way it gets
done in Las Vegas